Prof: Today I want to
talk about water and the law
that surrounds drinking water,
to talk about its quality,
talk about what your rights are
to clean water.
To also give you a sense of
what key threats are to drinking
water,
what your exposure might be,
and what we might do about it
both legally but also
personally.
Water is a critical component
of our environment and our
bodies.
Your body is close to seventy
percent water.
You can go for several weeks,
two to three on average,
without food.
You can only go for about four
minutes without air.
And you can go for maybe four
or five days without water
before you die.
So water is absolutely critical.
And one of the key arguments I
want to make today is that it's
a largely neglected area of
environmental law,
given the rapid increase in our
knowledge about chemical threats
to water quality and where those
threats come from.
So what are the major
challenges in water on a global
scale?
Clearly one is water-borne
diseases.
Diarrheal diseases are
recognized to kill between four
and five million people per year
in Africa.
Aquifers that cross property
and jurisdictional boundaries
are a critical issue.
So many rivers form the
boundary between nations or
between states.
The Connecticut River is a very
good example,
separating Vermont from New
Hampshire.
Point source control versus
surface runoff.
We've had a long history in the
last half of the twentieth
century of trying to control
point sources or pipe releases
to water supplies,
as opposed to thinking about
how chemicals may accumulate on
the surface and then be washed
into rivers that are used for
drinking water sources following
serious rain events.
Ground water depletion,
the Ogallala Aquifer in the
Southwestern part of the United
States and in the western part
of Texas,
is being rapidly depleted.
And its contamination is well
recognized.
Aquifers around the nation and
most industrialized countries
are now more intensively tested
than they had been before.
And it's recognized that they
contain chemicals that never
were anticipated to persist or
to migrate.
Private wells.
The Safe Drinking Water Act has
been established in the United
States to require testing and
control the chemical content
only in water systems that
supply more than fifteen
households,
fifteen or more households.
So if you grew up perhaps in a
rural part of the nation or you
live outside of New Haven,
you may have your own well,
as I do.
So I have a 600-foot-deep well.
And when I purchased my house,
I was quite happy with that
prospect,
thinking that water on the
surface would need to be
filtered down through the soil
before it got down into the
well.
And it was quite striking,
I had quite a lesson from a
well driller.
My well went dry one day,
I didn't know what happened.
So I called the well driller
and he came out and it was a
pretty remarkable lesson for me.
Within forty-five minutes,
he had pulled up the well head,
he had coiled the water,
coiled the pipe,
and I recognized that I hadn't
paid any attention to the fact
that the casing that surrounds
the well could convey water that
had been contaminated on the
surface down the side of the
casing and into the underlying
water supply.
I'll tell you more about the
plastics side of that story in a
few weeks.
So wells that service greater
than fifteen households are
regulated under the Safe
Drinking Water Act,
which means that if a chemical
is listed on the EPA's list,
then community supplies have to
test for the presence of that
chemical.
And if a maximum contaminant
level has been set,
that means that the provider
has to demonstrate that that
ceiling has not been breached,
or he or she would have to
install some sort of filtration
system.
So within Connecticut,
by the way, that means that
approximately thirty to forty
percent of the Connecticut
population is getting water that
is not managed in any way by the
Safe Drinking Water Act.
Surface water in the United
States is generally believed now
to be undrinkable for a variety
of reasons,
mostly because of biological
contamination,
the threat of E.
coli, but also giardia,
which is carried by both humans
and by animals in their wastes.
Monitoring and surveillance
needs much improvement.
I'll talk more about the
monitoring system that is
currently in place and why it's
deficient.
Public water infrastructure
also is inadequate.
How many of you know the way
that water moves from its source
to your tap?
What kind of equipment does it
go through?
What kind of filtration does it
What kind of land uses are
allowed in the watershed that
surrounds the lakes that provide
New Haven's water supply?
And what about the pipes that
convey the water to wherever
your tap is?
Do you know what they're made
out of?
Are they plastic?
Are they copper?
Are they bronze?
Are they metal?
Are they leaded?
There are many connectors in
many cities that are quite old
that are no longer allowed to be
installed that connect the water
main itself into your apartment
or into your house.
But they exist and remain
because it's extremely expensive
to dig up every connector and
replace it with one that does
not contain lead.
How about your faucet itself?
What's your faucet made out of?
Well, many faucets are made out
of brass.
And increasingly,
they're made out of plastic,
plastic that is painted to look
like it's metal,
painted silver.
You have to be really careful
when you buy a faucet system or
you put in a drinking water
supply system to really think
deeply about the source of the
materials and their leachability
into your supply.
The leachability is driven by a
variety of factors.
It could be heat.
So for example,
you certainly would not want to
make a cup of tea by turning
your hot water tap on and then
putting a tea bag in the water.
Or you want to feed infant
formula to a small child by
putting powder,
for example,
in a glass, and then filling it
up with hot tap water,
because the hot tap water is
likely to leach more compounds
from the pipe or whatever the
conveyance system is than cold
water would.
How long do you wait to let the
water run before you take a
drink out of your tap?
Makes sense not to drink water
that has been sitting in your
tap overnight or you come back
from vacation for a couple
weeks.
We now recognize that water
that sits in pipes takes up
contaminates from the conveyance
system.
So all of these issues are
worth thinking about in terms of
infrastructure.
How about water rights?
Really, what are your rights to
clean water?
And the core question of this
lecture is really how safe is
safe enough?
And how do we define safe,
particularly using the language
of the Safe Drinking Water Act?
And finally,
how does land use affect water
supply?
So many people are not at all
thoughtful about where watershed
boundaries in the vicinity of
where they live.
They're not thoughtful about
how chemicals can migrate long
distances.
I worked in California in the
Central Valley near Fresno for a
while on a project where
chemicals were recognized to
migrate more than five miles
from their point of application
to an agricultural field into
underlying aquifers.
So it depends very much on the
underlying surficial geology,
the soil structure,
the bedrock,
the groundwater regime,
how fast a chemical will move.
Some move really quite quickly,
others move really quite slowly
if they can bind to organic
matter.
So once again,
the Safe Drinking Water Act
covers supplies that have more
than fourteen connections or
more than twenty-four
individuals.
There are 53,000 water systems
in the United States,
and 43,000 of those rely on
groundwater and about 10,000
rely on surface water.
And they're roughly split
fifty-fifty, public and private.
And there are 15 million wells
in the United States that serve
individual residences,
and roughly 45 million people,
maybe fifteen percent of the
population in the nation are
drinking water that is
completely unregulated by the
Safe Drinking Water Act.
I wondered about this and I
wondered about what we could
find out about well water
vulnerability.
And also if a casing surround a
well is cracked,
that means that chemicals
applied to the surface have a
higher chance of migrating down
the inside of the casing.
So I asked the Department of
Environmental Protection and the
Department of Health here in
Connecticut if I could get a
hold of their database--
GIS, Geographic Information
System that they had that
identified the location of all
wells in Connecticut,
all wells that had been mapped
and geo-coded.
And then I overlaid that data
with surficial geology.
And then I started looking at
old air photos,
wondering about former land
uses.
And a pattern started to emerge
that in many areas that had been
former agricultural lands,
these had been developed into
residential areas and wells had
been dug into those areas and
provided unregulated water
supplies to almost a million
people in the state of
Connecticut.
It's kind of an interesting
story.
When I asked for that database,
I was denied access to it.
This was post-9/11,
because they were worried about
releasing the geo-coded data on
precisely where the wells where.
So I had to sign a paper that
promised that I would be legally
responsible for securing that
data and maintaining its
confidentiality and I would not
release it to anybody who could
do something nasty to a public
water supply.
So what about compliance?
How are we doing in the area of
compliance?
Well, 30 million people drink
water each year.
A little hiccup there for some
reason.
Thirty million people drink
water each year from systems
that report violations of
health-based standards.
There are about ninety-three
chemicals that are not now on
the Safe Drinking Water list,
that have maximum contaminant
levels assigned to them.
So 30 million people,
ten percent of the population,
drinking water that the systems
have reported are in violation.
Ten thousand systems violated
health-based drinking water
standards and about eighty
percent of the public water
systems have reported no
violations.
And EPA has issued 86,000
violations of federal
requirements to monitor or to
report results.
So the overwhelming number of
violations are associated with
the failure to monitor and the
failure to report.
So if you don't look,
if you don't monitor,
you can't find a problem.
And if you find a problem and
you're a municipal supplier,
that's going to cost a lot of
money.
You're either going to try to
pass that cost back on to
consumers as increased prices
per gallon for their water.
But certainly,
you're not going to want
to--there's commonly a delay in
reporting.
So what is an MCLG?
A maximum contaminate level
goal?
EPA established both the
maximum contaminant level,
which is a legally enforceable
limit.
But they also established a
maximum contaminant level goal,
which is a health-based
ceiling.
So you would hope that the
legal limit would be the same as
the health-based limit.
But that's really not the case.
So the Safe Drinking Water Act
creates the contaminate level
limit as the highest
concentration of a contaminant
that's allowed.
And it also allows a
cost-benefit analysis that's
required under the Safe Drinking
Water Act to consider what the
cost would be of meeting that
limit.
If the cost is found to be
excessively high,
they'll set a goal that would
be higher to protect human
health,
and allow a contamination level
to be higher than that.
So here's a chart that gets us
to really what our present level
of regulation is.
And you see that after the Safe
Drinking Water Act was passed
back in 1976 that no new
standards were enacted.
It's been kind of interesting.
So Congress basically gives EPA
the mandate to regulate and
monitor water supplies,
but EPA doesn't really do very
much about it.
This period in the 1970s and
early 1980s was a period that
EPA was concentrating on source
emissions from smokestacks as
well as auto emissions and also
a variety of pesticides.
But really, it was paying very
little attention to drinking
water.
So it added seven volatile
organic compounds in 1987,
about eleven years later.
Copper and lead were not
revised based upon new evidence
of their toxicity from data that
had been collected back in the
1970s until 1991.
So remember,
I argued earlier that there's
often this delay between
recognizing that a compound is
more hazardous than earlier
thought before the agency would
take action and set a new limit.
We're seeing the same thing
play out here.
Well, Congress was upset at
this delay and they demanded
that a variety of new chemicals
be added,
including thirty-nine
pesticides, volatile organic
compounds,
metals.
So these were added in 1991.
And then during the period of
the 1990s, seven years,
there were no new standards.
Well that's kind of
interesting, because you might
assume quickly that in a more
liberal administration that
you'd have more rapid listing
chemicals,
you'd have a more protective
character.
This is not the case.
So that the liberalism or the
conservatism of the
administration seemed to have
little influence on this rate of
adoption.
So today we're sitting here
with about ninety-three
different chemicals.
And just to give you a sense of
how limited coverage and limited
the protection level is,
think about this.
That among the thirty-nine
pesticides that are monitored
and have these maximum
contaminant limits,
there are approximately 1,000
more that are completely
neglected.
Nobody's testing for them,
but they're allowed to be used
on agricultural crops.
And many of these have not been
fully studied to know how they
move through different kinds of
ecosystems or different kinds of
geologic systems and what their
potential is to contaminate the
water supply.
Think also that more than 800
other chemicals,
including industrial chemicals,
have been detected in water
supplies by the U.S.
Geological Service.
And by the way, the U.S.
Geological Service is playing a
really unusual role in this
regulatory process in that they
sit within the Department of the
Interior.
They're completely unrelated to
the Environmental Protection
Agency.
But they're playing a more
vigilant role in monitoring
chemical content and hazards in
underlying aquifers,
as well as surface waters,
than the Environmental
Protection Agency had during
this period of time.
So this is a history of
neglect, of limited
surveillance,
and it's being driven by one
fundamental characteristic of
this statute.
This is a listing statute,
which means that every time a
new chemical is discovered and
EPA decides they hope to either
set a goal or to set a limit,
they're going to get a fight
from all the municipal suppliers
or the private suppliers because
the testing costs are going to
be passed on to them.
And these testing costs are
often not minor.
By the way, it's interesting to
think about what the effect
might be of establishing a new
chemical limit.
Well, it may mean that you need
to conduct a brand new type of
test.
It may also mean that you need
to install filtration equipment,
perhaps activated carbon
filtration, which is
extraordinarily expensive.
And the smaller the water
system is, the more expense it's
going to allocate per individual
household.
So if New York City,
for example,
is facing a new standard that
EPA has adopted,
they can pass the cost of
monitoring and filtration on to
a very broad group of people.
But if you have a much smaller
community,
say in the rural west of a
couple hundred people in an
isolated area,
that's going to be much more
difficult for them to comply.
So there's been a trend towards
source protection instead of
consumer protection.
And in part,
you can see this happening,
what the public response to
this has been,
which is to rely increasingly
on bottled water.
And many people have the
perception that bottled water is
much safer than tap water is.
Well, it's not at all clear
that that is the case.
Many people do not understand
the filtration techniques of
bottled water companies.
We don't really have clear
standards.
And also, many of the companies
that are marketing heavily in
the United States are now
foreign companies.
So the public's perception of
safety is really poorly founded
in scientific evidence.
Also, there's a story about
plastic.
What about the potential of
plastic ingredients to migrate
into water supplies?
I'll give you one example.
About fifteen years ago,
I had bottled water in my house
as we were putting in a new
water supply system.
And so the bottled water came
in a jug that was polycarbonate,
a five-gallon jug.
You probably have all seen
these, that you'd flip upside
down.
And I had left that bottle
outdoors, actually had been away
for the weekend,
it was delivered on a Friday
during the summer months.
And the temperature had gone up
to about 102.
And it was sitting on my
driveway in the sun when the
ambient temperature was 102.
So it was really baking.
So when I opened the bottle and
put it on the stand,
I found that it had a really
very acrid taste to it,
a bitter, acrid taste.
So I called the water company
and I asked the bottling company
what might that be?
And the response was,
"Oh, we'll have a new
shipment out to you right away.
It was probably just the
cleaning agent or the
disinfecting agent that we put
the bottles through."
Well, I studied the problem
more intensely and found that
they were using a disinfectant
that was actually a registered
pesticide.
And also this was perfectly
allowable because it makes sense
to try to disinfect water
bottles that are coming back
that may have had stagnant water
within them.
But somehow,
the rinsing process hadn't
effectively removed the cleaning
agent.
Well, the bottled water problem
goes on in that I looked more
carefully at the potential of
plastics to migrate from the
polycarbonate into water.
And heat, solvents such as some
biocides are mixed with,
also cracks in the bottles
themselves can cause the
chemicals to migrate more
frequently.
The offending chemical in this
case is bisphenol A,
and we'll talk more about that
later.
If you look across the maximum
contaminant limits and you
compare them to the public
health goal,
this study by the state of
California found that the
maximum contaminant limit,
the allowable concentration,
was often two,
four, even sixteen times higher
than the health goal,
which tells us that in many
cases the agency is making a
determination that we can be
exposed at a limit that they
believe is not health
protective.
There are other studies that
have demonstrated a similar
finding for other chemicals
besides the elements.
So one of the ways to think
about the effectiveness of any
statute is to think carefully
about how it's monitored.
So what sampling design should
be created in order to figure
out whether or not we're
effectively searching for
chemicals that pose the greatest
threat?
Well, I asked this question of
the New Haven Water Authority
and found to my surprise that
systems of twenty-five to a
thousand people are only
required to provide one sample
per month.
And it's pretty clear that
there are certain climatological
events,
like very serious rain storms,
that can wash contaminants off
of surfaces,
whether it's an agricultural
field or say a large shopping
center parking lot,
into surrounding water supplies
if they are nearby.
So thinking about the
importance of the sampling
period is really critical.
And if recent reports have
demonstrated compliance with
certain standards,
then EPA allows the testing to
be limited to only four times
per year.
And for some types of systems,
such as New Haven Water
Company,
they have not found certain
pesticides,
so they're allowed to monitor
only on an annual basis.
They can appeal to the
Environmental Protection Agency
to reduce the periodicity of
their sampling.
And this of course is very
important to them,
because it saves them a lot of
money.
Trizine herbicides provide a
really good example of this in
the Midwest.
So trizine herbicides,
they're known as pre-emergent
herbicides.
And they're commonly sprayed on
fields such as cornfields.
And they're sprayed during the
spring.
And the spring in the
midwestern part of the United
States is kind of famous for the
intensity of its rainstorms.
So the sampling design relative
to the rain events really proved
to be extremely important to the
findings.
You can pay more attention to
the slide online,
but these data demonstrate the
ways that increasing the
stringency of standards passes
costs on to water supply
companies and to people that are
served in really an inequitable
way that is dependent upon the
size of the public water system.
So I want to concentrate today
and tell you a story about this
chemical.
This is a trizine herbicide and
now it's about
twenty-seven-year-old story.
But atrazine has become
infamous as one of the most
heavily used herbicides in the
world.
Its uses in the United States
include food crops:
field corn, sweet corn,
sugar cane, sorghum,
winter wheat,
guava, macadamia nuts.
It's used also on nonfood
crops, such as hay,
pasturelands.
It's also used in forestry.
It's also used in residential
and industrial and recreational
areas.
On residential turf,
within parks and on
institutional turf.
Also on golf courses.
And it's used for landscape
maintenance.
And the whole idea behind an
herbicide is to kill other
species of plants so that they
don't rob nutrients away from
the desired or highly valued
plant.
So it's also sprayed on
roadways.
And this is an interesting idea.
It would be a great student
project.
Think about the number of miles
of roadways in the United States
that are treated with
herbicides.
My town is a good example,
little town of Killingworth.
They don't like to cut the
vegetation next to the
guardrails.
So what do they do instead?
They come along with a truck
and they just spray the side of
the road.
Next time you get on Amtrak,
take a look at the vegetation
that goes along the track,
and you'll see almost nothing.
You'll see it devoid of
vegetation.
How do they do that?
Is it just that they didn't
plant anything?
No.
Because seeds would blow into
the area and they would grow
unless chemicals were applied.
So along major highways in the
United States,
along state highways in many
communities in areas that have
guardrails,
along corridors that are used
for power lines or rail on the
runways of many airports,
pesticides are applied.
So if you count up the total
area in the nation where these
herbicides are applied,
you can quickly get up to
hundreds of millions of acres of
the landscape.
It's really quite striking.
So, you know,
finding a chemical such as this
in the water supply really
should not be that much of a
surprise.
But no one has really looked
systematically at where
concentrations of applications
are going on.
But I'll give you one example
of where you might conduct this
kind of a study.
And that's with golf courses.
So that about $225 million per
year in the United States are
spent on chemical treatments of
golf courses.
There is almost no landscape
that I could imagine,
including agricultural lands,
that are treated more intensely
than golf courses,
and particularly putting
surfaces.
So about $1,300 per acre of
35,000 acres of putting surfaces
are receiving quite a variety of
different biocidal compounds.
As a nation,
we need to think about where
are we applying chemicals the
most.
And we're doing it
predominantly to field crops:
field corn--
about 59 million acres of field
corn is treated,
sorghum, sugar cane,
sweet corn--in both processed
and fresh form.
So large percentages of these
crops are treated with atrazine.
So if you map out the
concentration of atrazine in
streams in the United States,
you see it centered on the
Midwestern part of the country,
and this is the primary
corn-growing region.
So what you find is
concentrations in the microgram
per liter level,
which is a part per billion
level.
And the maximum concentration
level, the MCL for atrazine is,
I believe it's three or point
three.
Excuse me, parts per billion.
And if you look across the
nation to the number of people
now that the Environmental
Protection Agency think are
drinking residues of this
chemical in the water supply,
you see this adds up to
millions of people.
So large circles,
like the one around Texas,
represent more than 8 million
people.
Circles around Florida
represent about 4 million
people.
So you see that they're finding
it in the water where it's most
heavily used for agricultural
purposes.
So this was first registered in
1958.
And by registered I mean it was
given a license,
it's like a driver's license.
So atrazine,
it's regulated under the Safe
Drinking Water Act,
it's regulated under the Clean
Water Act as well,
and EPA began a Special Review
that reserve for chemicals that
they have particular concerns
about in 1994.
Now Special Review has had a
rather infamous history inside
EPA.
And I have a good friend who
graduated from Yale who has
worked her way up to a high
level inside the agency.
And she refers to EPA's parking
lot.
And the parking lot is a place
where EPA stores chemicals,
not literally,
but figuratively,
when it decides it's not going
to take any regulatory action on
them.
So atrazine was put in the
parking lot,
so to speak,
receiving little attention for
much of the 1980s,
when these data came out,
when people realized that the
concentrations were going up.
When the parking lot fills up
with additional chemicals,
it basically means that the
chemicals take longer and longer
to receive review,
and you have a lower and lower
probability that health-based
standards are going to be set in
response to new evidence of
serious contamination or risk.
Another problem with atrazine
is that it's structurally so
similar to other kinds of
herbicides, including simazine
and propazine.
And it produces similar
chlorinated metabolites.
Metabolites are byproducts that
the compound,
the original compound,
breaks into.
That it makes sense to think
about how we might be exposed to
clusters of these compounds,
instead of treating them
individually.
So remember my argument earlier
that EPA's attention is focused
chemical at a time.
So they'll make a decision on
atrazine without thinking about
simazine or propazine.
But in terms of your exposure,
in terms of its behavior inside
your body,
there is a presumption that
chemicals that are so similar in
structure will behave similarly
in your body and pose a similar
threat.
So as a society,
we want the government to pay
attention to these mixtures,
particularly if there's a
plausible reason that we might
be exposed to the mixtures.
So in 1991, the MCL was set at
three parts per billion.
And the MCLG was set at three
parts per billion as well.
And the compliance was
determined based upon a running
annual average,
with quarterly samples required
by EPA or a single average
sample.
Also in the late 1980s,
this was classified as a
possible human carcinogen.
But then the Environmental
Protection Agency reviewed it as
not a likely human carcinogen.
Now, how do they make these
choices?
Well, they submit evidence to
what they call a scientific
advisory panel.
And I've had the experience of
sitting on EPA scientific
advisory panels for nearly a
decade and reviewing new
evidence of risk.
And the decision on the part of
the panel to recommend a
classification as a carcinogen
or not a carcinogen or a
chemical of high concern or low
concern,
it really depends very much
upon who is asked to sit on the
scientific advisory panel.
And I want to recommend to you
the work of a professor at
Harvard, Sheila Jasanoff.
Sheila came here as a visiting
professor for a while.
And her work has been very
important on what she calls the
fifth branch of government,
which are these advisory
panels.
So evidence is often so complex
that an agency is not really
clear what they're going to do.
Is the risk higher?
Is it lower?
Should we regulate?
Should we just warn people?
How are we going to manage this
chemical?
They'll submit this question to
a scientific advisory panel to
gain their advice.
Well, the political makeup of
these panels makes a terrific
difference in guiding the
ultimate outcome.
So the Food and Drug
Administration,
the Occupational Safety and
Health Administration,
EPA, most regulatory agencies
rely very heavily on these
scientific advisory panels.
But just because a scientific
advisory panel makes a
recommendation,
doesn't mean that you ought to
believe it.
Prior regulation,
they looked at the chemical
more intensely and they found
that prior regulation was
insufficient.
So that they deleted rangeland
millet in pineapple uses.
So instead of prohibiting the
chemical outright,
they would look at the
particular uses,
probably uses that did not have
a very high economic value,
and decided to go after those
to prohibit or further restrict
those.
They also used what they called
a restricted-use classification.
And pesticide law,
FIFRA, the acronym Federal
Insecticide, Fungicide,
and Rodenticide Act,
it has this restricted-use
classification.
And this is an interesting idea.
I was telling a section last
night that it's similar to the
idea of a pharmacist.
In other words,
in the world of
pharmaceuticals,
we had this intervening layer
of expertise so that the
pharmacist plays a role of
interpreting exactly what the
appropriate dose is for you.
So the physician doesn't give
you the drug directly normally.
Although this happens in a
hospital often.
But in a pharmacy,
you get access to a chemical
that poses certain risks because
experts are there behind the
counter to make sure that you're
getting the proper dose and that
you understand that there could
be drug interactions or that
there may be certain side
effects that you should be aware
of.
So this same concept was built
into pesticide law,
but in a very different way of
training licensed applicators.
So if a chemical is classified
as being restricted use because
it is more toxic or it's more
persistent or it poses a certain
kind of a health threat,
then someone has to be trained
before they're allowed legally
to apply it.
And within the pesticide
regulations there is a provision
so that supposing I went and I
got my license.
So I was licensed to apply
dangerous pesticides,
particularly in,
say, restricted areas that were
ecologically vulnerable or maybe
inside schools or hospitals.
So that I have the legal
authority to delegate that
responsibility to you.
And if you have no training at
all, makes no difference.
And I would tell you what to
do, I would tell you to follow
the label directions very
carefully.
But remember what I was saying
about literacy and background
literacy.
So how do you mix say a quarter
ounce of a toxic substance in,
say water or in kerosene or
some other solvent that it's
supposed to be sprayed in?
And how do you know that you've
got exactly the right
concentration?
Well, it takes some
mathematical skill to do that.
And I've run across a couple of
cases that I was describing last
evening where people that were
delegated this authority not
only had a minimum level of
literacy,
but also had virtually no
mathematical capacity to make
these kinds of judgments.
So EPA realized this eventually
and they started requiring
containers that were in a sense
foolproof,
so that you would tip it,
they call it a tip-and-pour
mechanism.
So you could pour out only the
correct proportion of the active
ingredient.
And then all you had to figure
out was whether or not you had
to add one or two gallons to it.
So this reduced the error rate.
But if you are spraying a
pesticide,
as an example,
and you've got a backpack on
and you've got a spray wand,
I mean, I could be spraying the
edge of this podium and walking
along.
My cell phone could ring.
I could stop.
I could look at my watch,
and then I could move on.
And the effect would be what?
Well, when I looked at my
watch, wherever the wand was
pointing,
it would get a dose that
probably would be dozens of
times higher than if I were
walking in a uniform way.
There's kind of an interesting
analog to that with respect to
spray planes or tractors.
So you can imagine a tractor
that has a bar across the back
end with holes on it,
such as it's going to irrigate
a field.
Well, the truck goes along,
gets to the end of the field.
It turns around,
comes back this way.
And eventually,
it covers the entire field.
Well, if it has the same
application rate,
the same emission rate from the
pipe regardless of the speed of
the truck,
where in the field are you
going to get the higher
concentrations?
At the ends of the field,
where the truck slows to turn
around.
Similarly, if you can think
about spray plane coming in and
spraying the hypothetical field,
which is the platform up here.
They pass this way,
then they come back and they
pass another way.
I've seen farm workers in
California standing there with
just shorts and a straw hat on
kind of waving as a marker for
the spray plane,
being sprayed repeatedly.
There's an occupational side to
pesticide control that I don't
have time to express to you.
But then you get this overlap
of the spray in the field.
So these kinds of practical
conditions have a really
important implication for how
you set up your sampling design.
So if you sampled in the middle
of the field that was treated by
the truck,
or the tractor,
you're going to get a lower
level of concentration than if
you sampled at the end of the
field.
The same may be the case with
respect to spray planes and the
way that they spray fields.
So the dance of regulation is
one where the government will
say,
"Look, we've got to cut
back your use,
we have to protect the water or
we want to reduce worker
exposure."
And the industry that
manufactures it will say,
"Well, you know what?
Don't cut back in this area,
cut back and restrict its use
on a specific commodity,"
probably one that is not an
economically productive one for
them,
or particular kind of use.
So the argument about what uses
are restricted as opposed to
which ones are prohibited gets
quite technical quite quickly.
So if a chemical comes back as
a recognized,
serious threat to human health,
that doesn't mean it's going to
be prohibited.
Prohibition is very unlikely.
I mean, there have been so few
bans in environmental history,
probably fewer than 300 bans,
outright bans of chemicals.
I've talked to you about a
couple of them,
DDT is a good example.
And aldrin and chlordane,
these are all pesticides.
But for the vast majority of
compounds,
instead, you get this minor
revision in the way the chemical
is allowed to be mixed or
applied,
it's put into the
restricted-use category.
It's allowed to be used on corn
but not on other crops,
so that the market share can be
maintained.
Here's a graph of the seasonal
pulse of atrazine in water
supplies that was recognized in
the Midwestern part of the
United States.
You can't see the years here,
but this is 1995,1996,
1997,1998.
And you see this pulse.
Because they apply it in the
spring and then the rains will
wash it into the surrounding
water supplies.
Well, so another sampling
design issue here that really is
critical to the effectiveness of
the statute is that if you
decided that you were going to
sample say in September of each
year,
you're going to miss this pulse.
So it's only by sitting down
and thinking about the method of
application,
the timing of the application,
and thinking about it in a more
systems or ecological manner
that considers climate,
that you would be able to pick
this up.
There was a very legal debate
as well about what this chemical
is doing, where it's moving.
And the U.S.
Geological Service found that
it travels actually hundreds of
miles from its site of
application.
So it's running off the fields,
it's getting into streams,
and it's getting into rivers,
such as the Mississippi River,
and it's moving long distances.
So this study found that some
states were receiving fifty
percent of their pollution load
from out of state.
So if atrazine is reaching say,
Louisiana but we know that it's
not applied in Louisiana,
what right do they have to sue
the Environmental Protection
Agency for the failure to
regulate that chemical's
application up in Ohio or
Illinois or in Minnesota?
And they do have the authority
to sue the Environmental
Protection Agency or particular
chemical companies that are
responsible.
So this trans-boundary movement
of these chemicals raises a very
serious issue.
And also, you've got to think
about the fact that many of
these cities get their water
supplies from these rivers.
And they use filtration systems
that do not have the capacity to
extract many of the pesticides
that are used.
So water is typically filtered
by running it through sand to
take out particulate matter.
Then it's treated with chlorine.
It's not normally treated with
activated carbon,
which could bind to these
chemicals.
Now, that should ring bells in
your head if you're concerned
about your own water intake,
because water is the most
consumed food in your diet.
It should ring a bell that you
should be concerned about the
quality of water in your tap and
you should think carefully about
the wisdom of using activated
carbon at the tap,
because it's not likely that
the government has kept it
perfectly safe.
So I'm going to scoot ahead
here with one final aspect of
this story.
The atmospheric transport of
some of these chemicals was a
surprise to many,
inside the agency as well as
the scientific community.
I ran into this in California,
when I found that a chemical,
dibromochloropropane,
that had been injected into the
soil in cotton fields,
had actually volatilized and
gotten up into the fog.
Anybody here from the Central
Valley?
Well, the Central Valley of
California, which is sandwiched
between the coastal range and
then the Sierras,
is a flat basin,
it's a former lakebed.
And climatologically,
it's interesting because a fog
will settle on that area and
stay there for a good part of
January,
sometimes December,
six to eight weeks.
So what they found was DBCP was
actually volatilizing and it was
detectable in the fog.
They found toxaphene that had
been applied in Texas in the
Great Lakes.
Then they found atrazine in the
Great Lakes as well.
So point six percent of
atrazine is deposited,
in one study,
in rainfall.
And the concentration of
atrazine in precipitation in
some areas where it had not been
applied, was one part per
billion.
And what did I tell you the
maximum contaminant level was?
Three parts per billion.
Fairly striking.
So it's moving long distances
in clouds and raining down and
perhaps acting as a pre-emergent
herbicide to areas where it was
never intended to be used.
So the degradation of the
chemical in aquatic environments
is increasingly of concern.
The half-life is between
forty-one and 237 days.
An average half-life of the
chemical of 159 days.
And Lake Michigan is a
repository for atrazine because
of its use,
particularly in Minnesota and
Michigan,
Indiana, Ohio,
and the pattern of rainfall in
that area.
So it's cold water,
it's low productivity,
it's high pH,
low nitrate,
and low dissolved oxygen,
all contribute to increased
persistence of the chemical.
So the estimated half-life in
Lake Michigan is about
thirty-one years.
So EPA conducted a study that
found that when they tried to
figure out what the mass balance
was of atrazine or is of
atrazine.
So atmospheric wet deposition
is about 2,493 kilograms per
year.
The watershed loading directly
and surface water runoff to the
lake is about 5,000 kilograms
per year.
2,500 kilograms exported to
Lake Huron and exported to
Chicago by water diversions,
a more minor amount.
And even the lake itself is
volatilizing the chemical.
So recognizing that the
agricultural practice of using
atrazine as an herbicide and
EPA's neglect of this compound
and misunderstanding of its
ecological behavior could cause
a gradual buildup to 182,000
kilograms of the compound
sitting in the lake.
It was really quite striking.
So I'm going to just pause with
reflections on the work of
Tyrone Hayes,
who is a former chemical
company employee,
a scientist who worked for
Syngenta.
And Tyrone Hayes has been
responsible for some
controversial work.
So he took his students and he
rented a tractor-trailer.
And they drove across the
country, taking a look at the
concentrations of atrazine in
leopard frogs.
And what was interesting about
his finding, because he sampled
from areas of the country where
the leopard frogs lived but
atrazine was not used.
And then he went into the heart
of the Midwestern atrazine-use
belt and sampled in those areas.
And he found obviously higher
concentrations in the areas
where it was used,
but he also found that these
frogs had both ovaries and
testes.
So his argument that this
chemical is hormonally active,
at least in the African clawed
frog.
And he also is claiming that
there are important lessons here
for humans, that this compound
could be also hormonally active
in humans.
"So atrazine (he argues)
in exposed males that have
ovaries in their testes also had
much smaller larynxes."
And larynxes are important if
you're a frog,
because it's a way that you can
understand where other frogs are
or other frogs can understand
where you are for reproductive
success.
And it's also recognized to
lower the testosterone levels in
frogs.
So I'm not going to go further
today, other than to suggest
that there's a whole emerging
area of concern now about
hormonally active compounds.
And atrazine is a good compound
to pay attention to.
Okay, that's it for today.
Thank you very much.